[Music]
family members of a woman at the center
of a high-profile missing children's
case are publicly defending her for the
very first time
Laurie valo is charged with two counts
of felony abandonment and the apparent
disappearance of her children Ty Lee and
JJ she has not yet entered a plea no one
has seen the kids since last fall
now valas mother and sister till 48
hours valo would never harm her children
they spoke to Jonathan Vigliotti in an
interview you will see first on CBS News
she's invested her whole life and those
children so we know there's another
whole side to this we don't know what it
is but we know her Lorri values mother
Janice Cox and her sister summer
shifflett insist
valo is a loving dedicated mother not
the monster they say is depicted in the
media I have to see my family
slaughtered on the news every day this
mob mentality of calling for you know
Laurie to be just hung in a public
square basically is what it feels like
authorities say Laurie's children 17
year old Ty Lee and seven year old JJ
disappeared last September shortly after
they moved to Rexburg Idaho from Arizona
according to the police Ty Lee was last
seen hiking in Yellowstone National Park
with her family on September 8th roughly
a week later JJ was captured playing
outside on a neighbor's doorbell camera
investigators say he vanished on
September 23rd but that's not true says
Cox who claims she briefly spoke with a
healthy and happy JJ on October 1st I
talked to him he just takes the phone
you know and he knows you know he knows
who we are
Rexburg police declined to comment
regarding Cox's claim that she spoke to
JJ in October cox provided CBS news of
phone bill showing the alleged call also
that fall valo married for the fifth
time
valo and her new husband Chad de belt
whose wife died weeks before appear to
be living in Hawaii without valo
children Laurie severed ties broke off
marriages with several husbands did she
ever express resentment for her children
never Oh No
police arrested valo in February on
abandonment charges and brought her back
to Idaho where she's being held on a 1
million dollar bail Coxon shifflett
believed ty lee and JJ are still alive
the kids aren't dead where could they be
daddy question that's a great question
as a loving grandmother as old as a
loving aunt you haven't even approached
that question with her where are the
kids
she can't tell us why not she's in jail
she's not gonna everything's recorded
she can't discuss anything about the
case and I'm positive beyond any doubt
that she hasn't harmed those kids for 48
hours
I'm Jonathan Vigliotti Los Angeles we
certainly hope the kids are okay you can
watch 48 hours Saturday nights at 10:00
9:00 central right here on CBS